[Music]
to the south of bushu 18 re of the shore
there is an island called Tanegashima my
forebears have lived there for
generations according to a legend from
ancient times the name Tanegashima the
seed Island is derived from the fact
that the number of inhabitants in spite
of the smallest of the island has grown
and prospered like seeds which once
planted grow and produce new seeds
without number some years ago in the
10-man era on the 25th day of the eighth
month in the autumn of the Misano tou a
big ship had arrived at dawn at
Nishimura bay no one knew from what
country it came there were some 100
people on board among them there were
those whose physical features differed
from ours and whose language is not
understood those who saw them found them
strange among them was a scholar from
great Ming China his personal name was
Goho but now nothing is surely known
about his family name the chieftain of
Nishimura at the time was or even Ojo
who knew written chinese well by chance
meeting with Goho he conversed with him
by writing in the sand with a stick he
wrote we do not know what country these
people on board come from they look
strange
do they not they are traders from among
the southwestern barbarians they have
some knowledge of the relationship
between superior and inferior but
otherwise they do not know about
property therefore when they drink they
do not use cups and when they eat they
use their fingers and not chopsticks as
we do they show their feelings without
any self-control and they do not know
the rig
script or the use of it such traders are
in the habit of roving from place to
place bartering things which they have
for those that they do not have they are
not very strange and are withal quite
harmless this video is sponsored by
Magellan TV built by film makers it is
basically a Netflix for documentaries
with the widest range of history content
available anywhere so if you are keen on
hearing more background about any of the
sources on the voices of the past
Magellan is a great place to start
featured genres include history crime
science and space with new documentaries
added weekly is available anywhere and
anytime and in 4k for no extra money so
it's well worth ago I currently am
binging on any and all documentaries
about ancient China I could find and
have enjoyed learning more specifically
about the struggles of China's
remarkable first emperor through the
service so click on the link in the
description for a special free trial for
voices of the past viewers thanks then
Arobin l.joe wrote 13 reef rum here is a
seaport called a Kogi where the family
whom I serve has lived for generations
the population of the seaport consists
of several thousands of rich and
prosperous households merchants from the
south and traders from the north go back
and forth there as continuously as the
shuttle on a loom now being anchored
there although it is not a deep port is
far better than here since the port is
sheltered and calm when the report of
the foreign ship was made to my
grandfather
Shigure Toki and my father Toki takka
takka takka dispatched tens of boats to
fetch the ship to a Kogi where it
arrived two days later on the 27th day
the Tsuchinoko
day
visiting the port at that time was a
monk shoo-shoo so a disciple of ryojun
in issue desirous of learning the
wonders of the one vehicle Lotus gospel
he was staying temporarily at the port
he was well versed in the Chinese
classics and known for his agility with
the brush he happened to me to go home
and they conversed in writing and Goho
filled two that he had found a true
friend in a foreign land there were two
leaders among the traders the one called
Mercia Cuccia and the other Kira schita
domoto they had in their possession an
object which was about two or three
Shaku and length as for its shape it was
straight on the outside with a passage
inside and made of a heavy substance
even though its inside was hollow its
bottom end was closed there was an
aperture in its side through which fire
who was applied its shape could not be
compared with anything else when used
some mysterious medicine powder was put
in it and the small LED pellet was added
at first a small white target was set
upon a bank when it was discharged the
man gripped the object with one hand
straightened his posture and squinted
with one eye when thereupon fire issued
from the opening the pellet always hit
the target squarely the explosion seemed
like the lightning and the sound like
rolling thunder
all bystanders covered there is setting
up a small target is like placing a Swan
target in archery one shot from this
object can make a mountain of silver
crumble and break through a wall of iron
someone with aggression in mind towards
a neighboring country would lose his
life instantly when hit needless to say
this also holds for the deer that
ravaged the rice just planted the many
ways this object can be used in the
world cannot possibly be counted on
seeing it Lord taki teki thought was the
wonder of wanders
at first people did not know what to
cool it nor exactly what it was used for
at last people called it TEPO firearm
that it was not known whether it was
named by the ming chinese or by people
on our island one day
Dakka Dakka said to the two barbarians
by means of double interpretation i do
not think that i am able
but i would like to learn to shoot it
the two barbarians also using double
interpretation answered if you Lord
would like to shoot it we would love to
teach you all its secrets
Dakka Dakka said can i really learn its
secrets the Barbarian said the secrets
lie only in rectifying your heart and in
squinting one eye Dakka Dakka said as
for rectifying the heart the ancient
sages taught people how to do it and I
have learnt it if generally one does not
follow the principle under heaven in
action movement and rest one will
necessarily end up in error what do you
mean with rectifying the heart however
is perhaps something different if you
squint with one eye you will not be able
to see what is far away why should one
therefore squint with one eye
the barbarians responded this is where
concentration comes in and is necessary
when concentrating a long vision is not
necessary closing one eye does not mean
that one cannot see clearly but the one
is concentrating and wishes to hit what
is faraway this is what you should
consider Lord delighted taka daka said
that corresponds to what Lao Tzu said to
see what is small clearly that is called
clarity that year the day of the
festival of the ninth day of the ninth
month fell on the kanuto day and this
day was chosen as the lucky day to shoot
the musket for trial the wondrous powder
and pellet were put into the barrel a
small target was set up 100 steps away
and lo and behold the target was hit
almost in dead center people were at
first startled then they became
frightened in the end however people
said in unison we would like to learn
regardless of the high price taka taka
purchased two TEPO from the barbarians
and kept them as precious treasures in
his house as for the art of grinding and
mixing the wondrous medicine taka taka
had his retainer Sasakawa Koshiro learn
it taka taka practiced shooting
incessantly from morning to evening as a
result he was able to convert the misses
of his earlier attempts into hits 100
hits out of 100 shots
taka Takas interest in the weapon was so
enthusiastic that he had a number of
iron workers examine and study it
carefully through months and over
seasons they worked with the objective
of producing a new musket the form of
the new weapon was much like the foreign
original but the workers could not
figure out how to close the bottom end
of the
arrow tock attackers interest they
neither in the wooden stock nor in the
ornament but in the way that the weapon
could be put to use at times of war
therefore his retainers far and near
practiced with it and there were many
among them who could score 100 hits out
of 100 shots now more than 60 years have
gone since this object came to our land
there are some grey haired people who
still remember the event clearly this
could happen because our Lord
TACA TACA procured the to tempo from the
above-mentioned barbarians and learned
to use them the first shot from then
reverberating through the 60 provinces
of our country moreover it was Lord taka
taka who made iron workers who learn the
technique of their manufacture and made
it possible for it to spread over the
entire country in ancient times people
chose the simile of one seed growing and
becoming new seeds without number and so
our island was called Tanegashima now it
has been the first seed in the same
manner the people of old said if the
virtuous achievements of the forebears
are not made clear to the world the
descendants are to blame for this reason
we have written this record
you